ううっう0
今から日本語の講座を行います
日本のスターバックスに興味を持っている外国人が比較的に多いみたいなので今日は
スターバックスジャパンのビバレッジメニューを紹介したいと思いますほとんどのもの
が言いづらいため実際の商品名を読み上げてからそのいやすい別名もいいます
マッチャークリームスプーン
別荘
グリーン4坪キャラメルしキーマカフェイン抜きの公開
エスプレッソコンパな味のついた中毒
ダークモカチップフラペチーノな
アイスカフェミストふわふわしたうつろさ
ほうじ茶飲みやすい服従さプラウストローベリーピンク用いフラペチーノ
春限定の陳腐さエスプレッソマキアート
ほろ苦い澱みカフェアメリカーン失望するスペースがある平凡さ
マンゴーパッションティーフラペチーノフルーティング気力
大人のフラペチーノてすプレスワーフガードフラペチーノ
パイプレイ好き通りココア不健康な癒し
コーヒースティーブビールスロードリップ日にストロベリーベリーマッチフラペチーノ
ぬ
濃縮された饒舌さオウムメイドバニーラティて店で作られた
バニララテミーティチョコレートティーフラペチーノ
どん底そこら無理
彼のスタバはどうだってまぁだいたいの味です
ただし日本より安いのでさらに魂が薄いです
me
ちょ待てよ動画あんたもスターバーによく行くだろ
そのとおりです僕がオチです